>> Tucker: MARTHA'S VINEYARD OFF
MASSACHUSETTS BUT FOR DECADES
PEOPLE IN MARTHA'S VINEYARD SAID
WE NEED MORE DIVERSITY.
IT WAS SENT ON A JET PLANE BY
DESANTIS AND THEY CALLED THE
ARMY AND HAD THEM SHIPPED TO
A MILITARY BASE.
PEOPLE WERE NOT UPSET AS DIVERT
WAS LED AWAY TO A MILITARY BASE.
WATCH.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> THOSE ARE CHEERS IN MARTHA'S
VINEYARD THIS MORNING.
JUST BEFORE MIGRANTS BOARDED
BUSES TO GO TO CAPE GOD.
>> Tucker: GO BROWN PEOPLE AND
DON'T COME HOME.
IF YOU ARE NOT MY HOUSEKEEPER,
GET OFF THE ISLAND IT SEEMS LIKE
THEY ARE BIGOT BUT ACCORDING TO
CNN THEY ARE JUST GRATEFUL.
CLAPPING IN GRATITUDE FOR RON
DESANTIS AND THE GIFT THEY GAVE
THEM.
THEY SAID THEY ENRICHED US.
WOW!
THAT DIDN'T TAKE LONG TO LEAVE
A MARK.
WITH VENEZUELANS THEIR LIVES
WERE CHANGED FOREVER.
LIKE THE GUY THAT CONVERTED
ISLAM BECAUSE HE SWITCHED PLANES
IN DUBAI.
WE LOOKED INTO IT.
IS MARTHA'S VINEYARD
CONGRATULATING ITSELF FOR
SURVIV
SURVIVEING A BRIEF ENCOUNTER
WITH HISPANICS?
YES.
THIS IS REAL: ING A BRIEF ENCOUH
HISPANICS?
YES.
THIS IS REAL:
[LAUGHING].
THESE PEOPLE CALLED THE ARMY IN
TO HAVE THE HISPANICS SHIPPED TO
A MILITARY BASE BUT THE
HISPANICS ARE GRATEFUL TO GO TO
THE MILITARY BASE.
THE FOUNDATION ALWAYS PRAISED
ISLAND RESIDENTS FOR RAISING
$40,000 BUT NOT REAL FOR THE
MIGRANTS BECAUSE NONE OF THE
MONEY IS GOING TO THE MIGRANTS.
QUOTE:
THEY RAISED MONEY FOR THEMSELVES
AND NOT FOR THE VENEZUELANS.
THE MOST INSUFFERABLE PEOPLE IN
ANY TOWN SHOULD BE THE CHURCH.
THAT'S ST. ANDREWS AND QUOTE:
[LAUGHING].
OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS WHOM HE
HAD DEPORTED INSTANTLY BY MEN